I'm joined Now by David boyzone thank
you very much indeed for joining me uh
you're one of America's greatest lawyers
I mean I don't say that lightly and I
realize that in the general scheme of
things probably this case actually isn't
that big a deal for you certainly not as
big a deal as it has been for us back in
the UK yeah I think that's probably
right although although it's still a
pretty big deal and it gets a lot of
attention because it involves a senior
member of our royal family obviously
it's been a year since prince Andrew
settled his his civil case with Virginia
Jeffrey your client
at the time that it was settled he had
until that point repeatedly said I'm
going to clear my name I'm going to go
all the way I'm going to go to court and
I'm going to have my day and I'm going
to clear my name and then at the last
minute he caved and paid a large check
were you surprised no no uh this was
never a case where I think he could have
afforded to go to trial that this was a
case where I think the the evidence was
too strong
and it would it was going to be very
difficult for him to give a deposition
it settled right on the eve of the time
when the court had ordered his
deposition to be taken and I think it
was a deposition that would have been
extremely difficult for him well
certainly with you because you're known
as one of the masterful deposes in legal
history you depose gilet Maxwell had you
got prince Andrew in front of you I mean
we watched the news night BBC interview
with toe curling enough but do you think
that did that give you all the
ammunition you needed do you think well
it gave a lot of ammunition but it also
said that this is a person who is not
going to want to sit for a deposition
um why well because I mean that was a
relatively short interview and while
there were some tough questions it was
generally very respectful uh interview
uh this was going to be a deposition
where he was going to have to sit for
seven hours and he was going to have to
ask and answer any question that was
relevant to the case he had said so many
things and his advisors had said so many
things to the Press on his behalf that
he was going to have a lot of difficulty
I think reconciling those things with
the factual evidence testimony that
people had given not just my client but
other people
he's been going around briefing people
who then briefed the media in the UK
that he only settled this to make the
problem go way in terms of PR Optics to
protect the queen and so on that he's
never met this woman none of it was true
blah blah blah it's interesting uh
he hasn't said anything to the Press
about this and nobody who is one of his
advisors or one of his attorneys has
said anything at least for the record
what we have is these innuendos from the
Shadows
saying he only did this because but
nobody will own up to actually trying to
come forward and say that because the
fact of the matter is not true and I
don't think anybody is prepared to put
their name to those kind of did you have
any doubt that Andrew was guilty
unless you're there
you know unless you're there witnessing
it or unless you've got a videotape
you never know personally what happened
all you can do is look at the evidence
and the evidence was very strong what
was more to you was the most damning
part of the evidence
it's hard there's so much
um
part of it was the photograph
I mean the photograph made clear that he
could not say he'd never met her
and again it's so often people
when they start to lie go so far
and they make statements that are
demonstrably untrue I mean he could have
said
um yes I met her yes I danced with her
but no there was never any sex
um uh that's something that may be hard
to disprove
um
when he says I've never met her
and you've got that photograph
and you've got a photograph that Maxwell
herself says she thinks is real well
funny enough she came out on talk TV in
this interview from her prison uh
several weeks ago and said she now
thinks the photograph is fake I I don't
believe it's real she said there's never
been an original further there's no
photograph I've only ever seen a
photocopy of it now the mail Sunday
newspaper then did a big investigation
on the back of her claim and actually
got to the original photographer and
there seemed to be no doubt this was an
original photograph right no do you have
any doubt I I never had any doubt
um I mean I mean for one thing
um the photograph looked real the second
thing nobody when they first saw the
photograph said this isn't real it
didn't happen right if somebody shows
you a photograph of something that you
know didn't happen you say that can't be
right because it didn't happen no one
ever said that it was only afterwards
they began to think well maybe it's
maybe we can make a claim that it's not
real or something like that but the
event clearly happened because if the
event hadn't happened from the moment
that photograph became public people
would have said it can't be so because
it didn't happen
Andrew again it was what we read in
briefings to the media so we're not
entirely sure how much is directly from
him it seems to be inferring that he may
now contest the settlement and he's
using as as a reason the settlement
between Virginia defray and Alan
dershowitz the lawyer obviously you've
been involved in all this but is there
any bearing on the two cases in that
sense not not in any significant way of
course Alan dershowitz
as part of the settlement admitted that
Virginia du Frey was honest in her
accusations that she actually believed
it was him
um so that to some extent strengthens
um I mean if Alan dershowitz who was one
of
one of Epstein's closest friends his
lawyer for many years was a spokesman
for Epstein with the Press if he is
admitting that Virginia honestly
believes what she was saying even about
him I think that strengthens her there
would be some who would say yes okay but
she also got it wrong and if prince
Andrew was to say she got it wrong with
me too
is there any way for him back into this
having settled in the way he did first
of all she didn't say she got it wrong
what she said was
that under all the circumstances it's
possible it might have been a case of
mistaken identity there's no doubt that
there was abuse here and it was a long
time ago she was very young it was very
traumatic situation and I think it was
inevitable to admit that there might
have been a case of mistaken identity
but the evidence
the evidence there was what is important
not the question of whether she thinks
it's possible that there was a mistaken
identity and as far as prince Andrew is
concerned
we've got the photograph we've got the
photograph of prince Andrew Maxwell and
Virginia there at exactly the time that
Virginia said and the date of that
photograph because it was what the daily
mail found out was that it was processed
at a Walgreens shortly after Virginia
said she came back from that trip so all
of the evidence with respect to the
legitimacy of that photograph I think
demonstrates that that photograph is
real and with all your experience of
these things
if you established that prince Andrew
was lying about the photograph
that he had met he had put his arm
around it it was with Gilly Maxwell at
her home with that in itself have been
enough do you think to get a conviction
I think it probably would have been
because
um you have her testimony
and you have his complete denial so the
question is
um is he credible or not and once the
jury concludes that he's not credible
about having never met her I think the
jury probably concludes he's not
credible about claiming that he did not
have sex with her and did you think
that's why in the end he settled well I
think it was partly that but I also
think that he recognized and I think his
lawyers recognized that it would be a
disaster for him to appear for a
deposition I mean remember as you say I
deposed Elaine Maxwell and she was
indicted for perjury as a result of that
as a that deposition and um I think he
would have been taking a terrible
criminal risk to appear for a deposition
where he'd have to answer these
questions under oath right and if he did
not answer those questions truthfully
under oath he could then expose himself
to real criminal liability so the risk
of of criminal uh liability over perjury
alone right could have ended up being
one of the more serious things he you
would face I think that's right you see
if you lie to a
interviewer you know you may embarrass
yourself if you lie in a deposition you
could go to jail
the Maxwell family released this bizarre
photograph of two adults in a bath
wearing masks of prince Andrew and
Virginia du Frey claiming it proves
conclusively the bath was too small for
any sort of sex frolicking when I saw
this on the front page of a telegram I
was like actually it proves to me they
can't exactly you know exactly right I
saw that and I said
people have had sex in a lot smaller
places right and I seem to be proving
the complete opposition it was just it
was incomprehensible to me uh one of the
things that has been a mystery to me
um throughout this is with prince Andrew
with Lane Maxwell uh with Alan
dershowitz why they say the kinds of
things they do publicly right when it
just it it doesn't help them it just
undercuts their credibility and
um and that interview that prince Andrew
gave the interview just that because
Lane Maxwell gives from a jail sentence
while while
um her case was being appealed why in
the world would you want to further
damage your credibility at that point do
you think she was just lying through her
back teeth in that interview
I I think she's a very troubled
person I think she's in a very troubling
situation I think she never thought that
she would find herself uh in jail
[Music]
and
I I think
I think it's very hard to know why she
says the kinds of things she says now
but I think she's under a tremendous
emotional pressure I think she's a very
damaged person
she's done a lot of horrible things but
I think it's it's hard as a human on a
human level not to have you know a
certain
empathy for you know the
the pain I'm sure she's going through
right now is there any legal way that
Andrew can
get back into this process again having
settled in the way that he did all he
has to do is ask he can if he wants to
well he can't unless we let him but uh
who would have to let him Virginia would
have to let him come back and and reopen
it but if he wants to
if he wants to reopen it he's got my
telephone number his lawyer's got my
telephone number right do you think he's
going to make that call I do not why
because he knows that if he comes back
he's going to be subject to exactly the
same scrutiny exactly the same
deposition exactly the same trial that
caused him to settle in the first place
and the allegations over which he
settled were serious I mean some of the
sex that he was allegedly having with
Junior Freight were in states where it
was unlawful she was underage
there's no doubt um that um uh he could
have been prosecuted uh criminally if if
prosecutors had either had jurisdiction
over him or wanted to I think one of the
things was disappointing to us in the
United States was how lightly the
British prosecutorial authorities uh
treated this you think that he because
he was Prince Andrew remember the royal
family he got an easier ride than he
should have done I don't know whether it
was because he was a member of the royal
family or whether he just was a wealthy
uh could afford good lawyers
our justice system in the United States
as well as in the United Kingdom greatly
favors people who are well represented
so I think that if he'd been an ordinary
chap who had done what he did I think
the prosecutors would have looked at him
differently do you think you'd have been
charged criminally I I don't want to say
that because I think you've got to look
at what the evidence is and um you've
seen all the evidence well I haven't
seen enough evidence to know about
criminal charges but it would have been
a distinct possibility I think it would
be a distinct possibility
extraordinary yeah there are also a lot
of some Epstein died in prison right
took his life or otherwise as some
people think but many other people who
were on that island with him presumably
up to all sorts of stuff they've all
remain secret because a lot of the files
have remained secret yeah yeah I I think
one of the troubling things about this
is Maxwell and Epstein couldn't have
done what they did for as long as they
did on the scale that they did it
without the support and collaboration of
many other people and I think one of the
very troubling things about what has
happened here is that although it is
good to see Maxwell and Epstein held to
account there are many many other people
who have not been held held to account
and and I think that the U.S attorney
Berman
deserves a lot of credit for what he did
but
the subsequent prosecutions I think have
left a lot to be desired
there are some very big names that were
associated with Epstein I mean do you
think there are some very rich powerful
people out there who perhaps should be
made more accountable for their actions
well I I think I think that's true and I
think there are also some maybe not so
rich and powerful people but that we're
collaborators uh who should have been
held to account
um I as I say you took the very tip of
the iceberg here and it was the most
important tip and if you're going to
take two people
Epstein and Maxwell were the right
people to take
um and and I think the the prosecutors
deserve credit for that
um and uh and and I think the victims
are grateful for that
um but I think the victims also believe
that there are a lot of other people who
should have been held for to account
that have not been held to account
you're also involved in many other high
profile cases one of which is Sam McMan
fried the ffcx guy you're actually
representing a high profile class action
suit against him but also against the
celebrity endorses yes including the
Quarterback Tom Brady his his wife at
the time Gisele uh bunchen comedian
Larry David the NBA Style Stephen Curry
tennis star Naomi Osaka it's interesting
I wrote a comma balance for the New York
Post saying well what about these
celebrity endorses why are they not
being made accountable exactly no
exactly right I mean so many of our
clients say
we invested because X say Tom Brady
somebody
um was endorsing this and we knew he
wouldn't endure something that wasn't
real right it gave uh FDX a credibility
that FTX would never have had otherwise
and he gave it credibility to the
average person on the street people were
not Wall Street speculators investors
but people some of them put their 401K
money into the into these Investments
and um and the stories that we have from
our clients who put eight uh eighty
thousand dollars in or a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars in maybe not a
large amount in the larger scheme of
things but it was their life savings do
you think these celebrities should be
personally liable then for some of this
I I think they need I think they need to
take responsibility and I think they
need to have some liability
um they weren't uh
core but they put their names
their names they put their names to it
and they misled people and um there's
also some legal issues like were these
unregistered Securities
um but just the on the human level they
lent their name to a fraud and by
lending their name to this fraud they
caused a lot of innocent people to lose
their money and I think they need to be
held some yeah I completely agree David
I could talk to you for hours that's
such an amazing and varied life but
thank you very much thank you it's good
to talk to you I really appreciate it
good to talk to you good to see you
thank you